hola buenos días fue muy tenso en la
verdad porque muchos de los miembros
demócratas de este comité en el senado
cuestionaron a barrett sobre sus
posiciones frente a obama que a la ley
de cuidado en salud a bajo costo y es
que básicamente los demócratas también
que al ser confirmada barrer la balanza
entre los miembros liberales y los más
conservadores al interior del tribunal
supremo- cambie y los republicanos
intenten acabar con este seguro de salud
que protege a personas con
preexistencias médicas como por ejemplo
diabetes o cáncer y es que la prueba más
importante vendrá para este ley en
cuidado en salud después de las
elecciones tan sólo siete días después
de las elecciones cuando la corte
suprema- escuche los argumentos de una
demanda que han liberado cerca de 18
estados todos los republicanos en cabeza
de texas
que el tribunal supremo- derogue acabe
permanentemente con obama
así que este es uno de los temas más
importantes que vimos en la discusión el
día de ayer en las audiencias dianas se
podría abordar el como barrett manejaría
las disputas electorales mientras trump
sigue señalando fraude electoral que se
espera para hoy
definitivamente este es uno de los temas
que se abordarán durante estas
discusiones y es que la confirmación de
barrett será muy importante en caso de
que después de estas elecciones
presidenciales alguno de los dos
candidatos solicite un reconteo y se
pueda registrar algo similar a lo que
ocurrió entre bush y al kurd donde el
tribunal supremo sería el encargado de
decidir quién es el presidente de los
eeuu y los demócratas han dicho en
varias oportunidades que precisamente
ese es el objetivo del presidente de
donald trump que a menos de un mes de
las elecciones él dominó a barrer y
espera que sea confirmada en el senado
también se esperan críticas frente a
como el barrio tiene una opinión
religiosa muy fuerte que podría no ser
digamos objetivo al momento de tomar
decisiones frente a la libertad
religiosa de los estadounidenses